learn Matlab from Phil Parisi Phil is a
PhD engineering student and his teaching
style is clear and to the point Matlab
is a programming language and software
suite used for data analysis scientific
Computing and visualizations and it's
widely used in Academia and Industry Hey
There YouTube we are going Zero to Hero
today in Matlab thanks for joining me
we're going to Jump Right In
right in front of us is the first screen
you'll see when you open up Matlab for
the first time this is called the Matlab
IDE integrated developing environment
this is the place that we do all of our
programming in Matlab
center of the screen we have the command
window this essentially serves as a
powerful calculator let's type some
stuff in here let's just do seven plus
eight or nine that gives us 16. we can
do 10 minus five that gives us five how
about the square root of 225 15.
what about square root of 15 times 9.
34.8569 right these are just quick in
and out commands to give us information
now if you look in the right we've
already got something popping up in our
workspace
we've got something called ants and if
you see after every time we run a
command we're getting this output ants
which is short for answer and it equals
the value of the previous statement that
we entered in ants is our first variable
that we've created if I just ask Matlab
for the value of ants it'll spit it
right back out to me as the most recent
answer that was spat out
if I were to do this again and say 8
plus 2 answer is now 10 you can see the
workspace variable has been updated to
10 and I can ask for ants and it's 10. I
can also do ants plus nine and we'll get
19. Matlab is holding this ants variable
in memory
we're getting kind of clogged up here to
clear the command window
CLC and hit enter and that'll remove all
that crap in the command window all of
our previous statements are now gone but
they were executed which is why ants
still holds its value
right here and still equals 19 even
though we just cleared away the
lettering with CLC
if you want to actually clear the
workspace variables you'll need to use
the command clear vars this is one word
you hit that boom now there's nothing in
our workspace and if I ask for ants I
get nothing out because ants doesn't
exist right now
let's try creating some more variables
with actual nice names that we can use
such as x equals 10 and Y equals 20.
here in our workspace we now have two
variables X and Y with values 10 and 20
and we can use those variables to do
further mathematics here we've used X
Plus y equals 30 and 30 is saved to our
ants variable of course we can ask
Matlab for just the x value and just the
Y value that we created
CLC to free up our Command window
there's another cool way to see our
workspace variables and that's by typing
whose
just type that and we'll see the names
of our variables that exist here
notably this column the class column
will describe what type of variable
these are
in many programming languages handling
the types of variables are very
important luckily in Matlab 95 percent
of the time we're only going to be
dealing with doubles double is just the
way that Matlab holds the data that
belongs to x y and all the other
variables that we create
this is a nice Bridge into other types
of variables such as strings
let's call W equals the word new
no problem this isn't a number right
this is the word new and if we type
whose we'll see that Matlab has now
created w
as a Char this is short for character
characters in Matlab are defined when we
use single apostrophes around a string
of letters or numbers
if I do two apostrophes such as Z equals
York
with double apostrophes on either side
and I do whose
now we're seeing w
is still a char
and Z is now a string
these three chars doubles and strings
will cover almost anything you need to
do for basic Matlab and we're not going
to go any further beyond the data type
discussion for now
that's clear on workspace and start
fresh
one thing you may have noticed when we
Define these variables
every time we hit enter Matlab provides
an output here
if we don't want that output we can
simply add a semicolon at the end of the
sentence
like this
these semicolons are called suppression
they prevent Matlab from outputting a
line of code so
Matlab still runs that
everything we do in this before the
semicolon Matlab still acts on for
example if we Define x equals
X plus seven
we run this
this line is still run but we just don't
see an output
by the way you'll notice that our X
variable is now 26. why is that
the programming language moves
sequentially in this line X was defined
as 19.
when we run this line
X right here is replaced with 19
adds 7 to 19 and you get 26 on the right
hand side of this equation that value is
stored to X
if we ask for X Out X is now 26.
another piece of useful Punctuation is
the comma
let's say you want to add multiple
things on one line I'm clearing out
everything right now let's say you want
to do Define
U is 25
and then me
is 10.
if I run this I can now act two things
on one line
two commands for one line they both
output here
if you didn't want them to Output what
would you do
you'd add semicolons at the ends of
these lines in fact at the end of each
expression
so after 25 and after 10.
briefly hit the up arrow in your
keyboard and you're going to see that
you can access all the old commands that
you were using
I'll bring this one back at a semicolon
here and a semicolon here and we'll see
no output but these two lines are both
run
we've seen a few popular operators I can
do U plus me I can do U minus me I can
do U divided by me U times me
you
to the power
of me use that carrot on your keyboard
to do the power
we've seen square root as well
square root of U is five
one thing to note you can do compound
Expressions if I do the square root of 8
times 9
. that's going to give me the correct
answer the same as the square root if I
defined X as eight
times nine and then did square root of x
these two expressions are essentially
the same thing X is just holding 8 times
9 and we're plugging it in here
whereas here we're just putting 8 times
9 in directly but it's the same thing
mathematically and you can see we get
the same answer out in both cases
again you can always check to see what
variables exist if you use the whose
command and they're all displayed here
that covers how our workspace works on
the right if you want to view these
variables in further detail you can
always double click on them this would
be useful when we have matrices and
things like that that are not just a
single number in a corner
other aspects of the Matlab IDE on the
left we have the current folder this
should be the place that you're actively
working in and saving your Matlab
scripts to
this will be more important later
the toolbar is up top this is where you
can create new scripts and files open
things import data you know it's kind of
just your overseen software component of
the actual Matlab syntax
you might be envious of the dark mode
I've got going on if you want to also
change that go to your preferences go to
colors
and this screen should show up
uncheck the use System colors box set
your background color to Black and your
text to White
you can also copy all the remaining
colors that I've got set up here
it's up to you though what your color
preference is I like high contrast
this is also a great place if you're
looking to modify other things in your
editor and debugger you want to change
the font sizes things like that you can
all do it from this preferences tab
you've seen so far that Matlab can act
as essentially a calculator on steroids
but it's not very useful if we're just
typing line by line and having to use
the outputs that we create let's create
a new script
to do this you can click the new script
button in the very top left or click new
and then script
these are very powerful and you're going
to do the majority of your programming
in these Scripts
the power of them is that you can type
multiple lines of code without anything
happening to the Matlab command window
you can see I typed clearvars but yet
the workspace hasn't been cleared and
that's just because I've typed these but
I have not run these commands yet
to do an actual running of your script
you have to click the Run button
save and run we need to save this file
I'll just call it basics
we run it and now look our Command
window is giving us the output of x
equals 10 which was the result of this
line
also it cleared all the previous stuff
we had in our Command window and we
cleared all the variables so now we only
had X after we created it
this is the real way we're going to code
in this beginner course and the way that
you should structure all your programs
from here on out
you can do things like x equals X plus
seven
add in W equals X
plus y
suppress those run this and we'll get no
output because we suppressed every
single line of code
but w x and y all exist in the workspace
because we ran these lines and they were
all assigned during this process
if we wanted to see a variable we can
check in the command window or when you
run this script you can just ask for
that variable to be outputted
and there we run it again and you get W
equals 27. I'm running this the cheating
way I love doing it control
and enter is the quick way to run your
Matlab Scripts
you can always use this run button at
the top as well
let's clear out our script and our
workspace using CLC and clearvars and
start fresh here for a new topic vectors
and matrices
let's add a heading for our script and
you can do that using the percent sign
yes it's percent I know it's weird but
it's Matlab standard for adding comments
comments are very useful you can add
them all over your scripts so that you
know what values you're defining and why
very often we know why we're doing stuff
in the moment
but many many days later even minutes
later you're going to come back and
wonder why you needed to do something
you can add comments on whole new lines
like this you can also add comments in
line like this
new line and inline comments
and then when you run your script using
control and enter
you'll see that the lines these comments
aren't even included
Matlab still goes through and creates
the variables as such
this section will call matrices and
vectors you're in The Matrix laboratory
I hope you know some linear algebra and
some basic Matrix operations if not stay
tuned we're going to learn them
first things first let's always start
off our script by clearing our Command
window and doing a clear vars operation
that ensures that every time we run this
script we're going to have a fresh
output
anything that was previously outputted
will be cleaned out and we're always
going to have any new outputs that we
call Fresh in the command window
and then clearvars will always wipe away
the stuff from our last script and allow
us to Define new variables that'll be
available in the workspace at the end of
the script this is good form
for our first vector and vectors and
arrays are going to be used
interchangeably let's say x equals 1
through 10.
I typed a colon when I said the word
through
if we run this with control enter
here x is defined as 1 2 3 all the way
to ten
it's not just a single value anymore X
is a vector or an array
even in the workspace we see here it's
defined as such holding these 10 values
let's type who's in the command window
and we'll see that X is still stored as
a double but it's a 1 by 10 in size
this is because Matlab uses the standard
and linear algebra to do one row by 10
columns
this is a horizontal array it's one row
of values
10 columns across
if you want to switch this I could do X
transpose transpose is just a single
apostrophe I run this and now we see
the answer out is a vertical array
X start out as horizontal I took the
transpose and ants is now a vertical
array
we take a look in our Command window
ants is a ten by one it's ten rows by
one column X is one row by ten columns
very important to keep this straight As
you know
we can also Define arrays and vectors
using the linspace function
x equals the Lin space
and the arguments here are going to be
the value you want to start with and
then the value you want to end with
if we run this oh my gosh we have a ton
of stuff in our output
it's because linspace will automatically
generate 100 values between 20 and 50.
and that's we're seeing here and these
are evenly spaced values
if I did from 0 to 100
we're seeing 100 at the end and we start
at zero
you can add one more argument to Lin
space and that will be the number of
terms you want the default is a hundred
evenly spaced terms but if I ask for 101
for example now I get even numbers here
because a hundred and zero are included
in these 101 values I can also do 20 and
now we're only a one row by Twenty
values a 1 by 20 double as our workspace
tells us
linspace is the first function we've
encountered and will cover functions
extensively throughout this training
when you have a function this is a
built-in tool that Matlab has for us to
use freely
you're going to always open up functions
with parentheses
and functions take arguments these are
the values that are inputted to tell the
function what to do
here our first argument was Zero our
second argument was a hundred and our
third argument was 20. each argument is
separated by a comma
note that Matlab doesn't care if you
have spaces or things in between as long
as you have commas separating your
arguments
no difference in the output
another way to define arrays and vectors
is simply to do it manually
to do this you start by opening a
bracket and then you type the values you
want let's say 12 50 negative 8 negative
100. close the brackets and run this
there's y 1250 negative 800 just as we
specified here
the only separator I'm using is a space
you can add different spaces in here run
it and Matlab won't care at all it'll
give you the same output
I'm going to suppress these outputs for
now as well
the important thing is that there is at
least one space between you can also
separate these with commas
or no comma
run this
still the same output nothing's changed
here so commas or spaces to separate
values in an array or vector
let's call our first Matrix a and we'll
Define it as a two by two
we'll call the first row one and three
separated by just a space and to do a
new row you have to use a semicolon
and then 2 and negative 10 will be our
third and fourth values
if I run this here's a 1 3 2 and
negative 10 ordered as we discussed
because I have this semicolon here
I could also add optionally commas
between those values and we'll get the
same output
if I want to add another row no problem
88 and 99 we run that and we added a
third row here
Matlab
will follow every single rule of linear
algebra
and it assumes you want to do linear
algebra throughout your mathematics
for example if I want to add a value to
a
it'll follow the linear algebra rule
which is add that scalar value to each
of the positions in The Matrix
99 plus 2 is 101.
same thing with multiplication a times
eight
every single value will be multiplied by
eight
what happens if I do a times a
if we run this and we've gotten our
first error in Matlab just grow to love
these errors but they're trying to help
you it's going to be frustrating when
you get them read these errors
extensively
you'll see here incorrect dimensions for
matrix multiplication ah okay a is a
three row by two column Matrix
linear algebra rules state that we
cannot multiply a three by two by a
three by two
that inner Dimension has to match what
we could do is take the transpose of a
and do this
a is a three by two but a transpose is a
two by three
right here two rows by three columns and
thus when we do this multiplication it
works out it follows the rules of linear
algebra
but what if you don't want to follow
those rules let's say you've got x
equals Lin space 0 to 100 you've got
your 100 evenly spaced values and you
want to take I don't know the square of
X so you want to do x squared
well matlab's going to throw you for an
error once again because this is a one
by a hundred Matrix and you can't
multiply one by a hundred by a one by a
hundred but what if you just wanted the
square of every value you wanted zero
squared 1 squared 2 squared
to do element-wise operations that's the
difference here you can do Matrix
operations or you can do element wise
operations
element wise operations
need a dot in front of them it's going
to be weird to get used to I know but
the dot is exactly what you need
if I run this
it goes through X and takes every value
squared
it's not the best example let me just
add 101 here so we get even values and
now you'll recognize this is 0 squared 1
squared 2 squared 3 squared 4 squared
right all the way down we should get a
hundred squared to get 10 000.
remember arrays in vectors are simply
along one dimension like x equals 22 to
100.
along one dimension matrices are along
two dimensions
there's a few more handy ways to Define
common types of matrices if you want to
make a matrix of all zeros you'll do
ones and then add an argument here
this creates a three by three Matrix of
ones very simple if you wanted to change
those Dimensions you could do something
like this and it gives you purely a
three row by one column array of ones
if I wanted to do B as all zeros I'd do
zeros let's give it the argument of ten
it gives me a 10 by 10 matrix here you
can always check that in your workspace
too
similarly if I want just to do a two by
eight Matrix of zeros here's two rows by
eight
and the last one that we'll cover
briefly is going to be the identity
Matrix you'll use I
I just like the eyeball in your face I
of three and we'll get an identity
Matrix which is just ones on the
diagonal
again can I add B and C together
of course not the matrix dimensions must
agree and Matlab will continually remind
you of that I can add C and C together
that's not a problem same dimensions and
I'll get twos along the diagonal because
of the summation
a cool trick here as well when I had X
was one to ten
there's actually one more argument that
we can add here
and it's going to be this value between
the colons
if I do this we get what we've been
expecting one to ten
but think of this as start at one
Jump by one value
end at 10.
if I wanted to jump every two values run
this and I get one plus two is three
plus two is five plus two is seven plus
two is nine if I added another two I'd
be beyond our upper limit and thus it
stops at 9 and doesn't go to ten kind of
Handy if you ever need to jump values
quickly
let's clear everything out and start
fresh here
an important part of working with our
matrices will be grabbing certain values
out of those matrices to use them for
further calculations
let's start for another example here
basic a 5 3 4.2
it's going to be a that's a one row
let's do eight nine and zero as our
second row
easy good start
let's say I want to grab out one of
those values how about this nine
how would I do that
we can use something called the index
the index goes through a matrix or array
or any variable and pulls out elements
of those variables
here a is a combination of all these
individual elements including nine
to use the index you're going to have to
use parentheses
then within those parentheses you
specify the location of the element that
you want
here it's nine I'm going to call a
second row
second column
and our output
is 9.
if I want to access that zero that's in
the second row
third column
let's say I want to add that 0 to that 9
just like this
we're specifying this value second row
third column
which is zero and we're adding it to the
second row second column value of nine
if you just have an array say a was only
this it's just a simple 1 by 3 Matrix
to grab a value out of that
you can just specify a single number so
A1 would be 5 A2 would be 3 and A3 would
be
4.2
this is going to be very frustrating for
programmers of other languages because
Matlab uses something called one
indexing
that means that in the memory Matlab
stores the first value of something as
the first index
this is because of the nature
of doing Matrix algebra linear algebra
needs this to be in the first spot there
is no such thing as a of zero
array indices must be positive integers
or logical values
final note on this you can also use end
as an index
that'll grab you the last value in a
matrix
this is convenient for let's say you've
got a equals Lin space
you know I don't know
220 to 900 and then you've got b equals
one by every five to
98 980 like this and you want to find
the last value of these well I could
tell you right now Lin space has a
hundred values in it but for B I have no
idea how many values are in this so I
can just call B end and I'll get the
last value out of B
from there you can work your way
backwards if you want you can call B end
minus 10.
it'll go back 10 spots okay this isn't
the end quantity minus 10 this is go to
the last index and then pull back 10
spots so if we open up B here
go to the end of B
976 and go 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 9 26.
that's what we got right here very
different from B
and
end parentheses here which grabs 976 and
then subtract 10 which is simply 976
minus 10 which gives us 966. important
differentiation there
we will use these indices further when
we get into Loops the last thing I want
to note on it is that we can use these
indices to change values of our matrices
I've just got another very basic
array set up here
and I want to do
this one value
I want to change it to a hundred let's
say it was a typo or something
I can do a 1 comma 1.
and then set that value equal to a
hundred
I'm going to Output a afterwards and
we'll see that I've now corrected this
value the first row and First Column
value to 100.
and we see it here in our Command window
you can also pull out entire rows and
entire columns I've only shown you how
to do this with single stuff right now
like asking for the first row second
value of two let's say I want the entire
second row here to be outputted
you're going to use that colon again
what you'll do is you need to determine
what you want so here we want the entire
second row so that means that we want
the second row and instead of specifying
a single value
I'll just say give me them all
and the colon will give you them all
boom
you can also think of this as giving you
the first value through the third value
this is the second row First Column
second row second column second row
third column and one to three just gives
us
the one two and three
if you want just the second row first
and second values the five and the four
there you go
and if you ever want everything you
could just do one to end in case you
didn't know what the end of this Matrix
actually was
short and sweet we're moving along well
let's keep going
let's take a look at a real world
problem that you're likely going to be
solving
what is the maximum value of the
following equation on the Range 0 to 5
we have the expression for y here
what is the minimum of that function
what is the x value where the maximum
occurs
and then Part D is what is y if we input
20.7 for x
this is exactly the type of problem you
guys are going to see in the real world
let's go through step by step but you
need to unthink
how you typically solve these problems
if you just had pen and paper you take
the derivative of y you'd set it equal
to zero
and then you'd find what points are the
maximum and minimum right typical very
standard approach
however
we have a computer we have processing
power we can calculate a bunch of
different things
so rather than solving this for One X
value what we're actually going to do is
generate X values from 0 to 5 and then
calculate a bunch of Y values that
correlate to those X values
and then we'll just pick out the largest
y value and pick up the minimum of the Y
values and then part C and D we'll have
to learn some more stuff as we go but no
problem your brain is putting right now
because you are learning so much let's
get back into Matlab
here we are with a fresh slate as I
mentioned let's first generate a bunch
of values between 0 and 5. I'm using
linspace so that'll give us a hundred
then at each of those X values let's
calculate a y value
and let's start easy here because it's
very easy to get lost when you're
writing these equations we want to do x
minus
3 for the equation and let's just run
this for now let's make sure that as we
progress and add terms we're not getting
errors
this works we've now calculated what x
minus 3 is and this is element wise
stuff X is technically a vector it's a 1
by 100 vector and so is y right now 1 by
100 because every value in X is just
being subtracted by 3 right now
let's take the opposite of that for the
equation and now we need to multiply
this to the second power
squared
if we run this we're going to get an
error why because this quantity here is
an array
it's a 1 by 100 array
and it's being multiplied by itself
right we're squaring it
math in Matlab is Matrix algebra
thus it's trying to do a one by a
hundred times a one by a hundred matrix
multiplication and that's what we're
getting this error
think how do we do element wise
operations we just want each of these
X's the first value of x
to be squared the second value of x to
be squared technically first value minus
three to be squared second value minus
three to be squared that's an
element-wise operation
add a DOT it even tells you right here
to perform element wise Matrix Powers
use Dot and then the carrot that's
exactly what we want let's add the dot
in there
good
and then finally we need to add 10 at
the end
to ensure that order of operations are
happening and by all means Matlab is
extremely smart and will do these
appropriately it's more so for us as the
programmers I like to add in extra
parentheses do not do not do not add any
other type of brackets or braces no no
no no
brackets are used when you define
matrices right a equals zero and one
that's only only only for matrices and
arrays all right parentheses are
dedicated for orders of operations and
for indexing
so use multiple multiple you can do
double things here whatever you want
do not use brackets do not use braces
don't use these things no no no no no
those are for other things in Matlab
just the parentheses here
and then I'm adding 10 afterwards
great so I've got X on the Range 0 to 5
y
taking those X values subtracting 3 from
each of them squaring that quantity
taking the opposite of it and then
adding 10 to it fantastic
but I'm a visual person I love to see
things and that's how I learn and
understand if you are too then this just
isn't doing it for you yes you have all
these values and we can find the maximum
one but let's first plot this
we're going to use matlab's plot command
and just give it the x value and the Y
values that you want to plot against
each other
hit enter and we've made our first graph
in Matlab and it's beautiful
x-axis are our X values from zero to
five Y axis we see goes from about 1 to
10 and we have to find our Max y value
looks like it's going to be around three
right now but this just gives us a good
idea of what we're working with
we're going to cover plotting more
advanced later in this but for now basic
plot
what's actually going on though is that
this isn't a contiguous line these are
just all the 100 data points that we've
plotted
really quickly just change this
and add this argument
you're adding a character star
put that in there and you'll see on this
graph all these little stars are the
data points that we calculated that's
what I'm talking about we've got a
computer here that can do mad
computation let it do its thing
also now that we've got plots being made
I've added this close all command that
will close all those figures that we
have up every time we run a new script
and when we plot it'll be on a brand new
figure so we get the new plot showing
every single time
but we still have to answer the question
what is the maximum y value and this is
where matlab's built-in functions come
into play Matlab literally has a
function called Max
if we give y as the argument we'll get
the maximum y value out right here
you can see it's just about 10
. the reason why it's not 10 is because
we're not checking every single infinite
value that exists between 0 and 5. we're
only checking a hundred of them because
that's what linspace gives us
is this answer correct just about it's
pretty darn close to 10 but note that
this is a numerical solution
whereas 10 would be the actual
theoretical solution
if you want to find the minimum value
how would you do that
well you've likely figured out that
minimum Y is probably the one that'll do
it for you and this one comes out to an
even one
but let's say you didn't know the name
of a function right I clearly know Max
and Min those are easy but if you're
looking for more advanced functions how
would you even begin to find this
Matlab provides awesome ways to get help
first and foremost is my favorite you
click this little FX down here and this
opens up a search for functions
boom I've already got minimum searched
in here and you can see all the
functions that in the description have
minimum in it
if you want to take an integral of
something you're going to search
integral in here and boom numerical
integration all these different things
that are built into Matlab that you have
at your disposal
maximum again
here we are
let's say you want to round values
ceiling floor fix you've got all these
options take advantage of this tool
simply by clicking the little f of x in
the bottom of your screen
however I've now found these functions
how do I know what their arguments are
Matlab has this covered by doing help
and then the function name
if you run this in your command window
and then open it up a bit more you get
documentation on this function
men minimum elements of an array it's
the smallest element in the vector X
what's X right here it's your argument
and it tells you all these conditions
for what this function does
you can also type doc and then the
function name and it will open up
matlab's online documentation for this
function
it's basically the nicer version of what
we saw in just plain text there before
you've also got this help bar that you
can search in I can look for the maximum
search this and I'll see that there's a
cumulative maximum function some sort of
name length Max and moving Max this is
the max that we're going to be using
here just the maximum elements of an
array there is so much help and guys if
you aren't peeing your pants right now
and subscribing to this YouTube channel
oh if you've lost your mind this is gold
as a programmer you are never ever ever
ever expected to know all the functions
and all the possibilities of a
programming language no no no no you
need to know the basics and then you
need to know how to find information
that you need
almost every time that I program in
Matlab I end up going online going to
this documentation and searching for
something new
the other way to do it you open up a new
browser on the web and you say how to
find the minimum of an array
in Matlab
look this up boom MathWorks website has
a hint boom right here all this help is
available guys you are not alone do you
see when I was searching for this right
here look in Java python C plus plus
JavaScript they're in Matlab already in
C everyone everyone has to get help in
these languages the internet is the best
resource for you guys the world is your
oyster here take advantage of it
anyway I digress
let's get back to our problem
all right we found the Max and the
minimum using the Max and Min functions
at what x value does the maximum y value
occur okay with a maximum y value I
think we found was about 10 so we need
to go back and find that x value
in our script let's take a step back
we've got Max of Y that's good but we
need the index of that right at some x
value
we put it through this function here and
we got some y value that was the maximum
so if we work backwards we might be able
to get that index
and this is where reading about the
functions help
Max let's take a look here
this third paragraph m i max of X also
Returns the indices into operating
Dimension corresponding to the maximum
values
oh that's exactly what we need the index
is what we want let's try a couple
things here let's try first let's just
save this to Max Val
and do Max y
I'm going to suppress some output here
we don't need a plot right now so I'm
going to comment this line out so Matlab
won't even run this and now if I run
boom we're just getting that maximum
value out as we saw before though in
that help thing it said if we do M and I
we're going to get the maximum value and
the index of it
if we run this we get two outputs now
this is how you take multiple outputs of
a function you actually pass it in a
matrix of values and then the function
will assign appropriate values to these
outputs
now I've got I equals 60. that means the
60th value of I if we open up sorry of Y
if we open up y one two three four five
six you know if you go all the way over
to 60
should be boom right there the value
we're expecting
that means the 60th value in X is the
One X value that gives us the maximum y
value 60 right here so
2.9798 of course guys you don't have to
go and open this up every time we're
smarter than that we can just do X of 60
and that'll give us the x value better
yet let's come here and let's do
x max Val
equals
X of I
what is this I it comes out of here and
it has the value of 60.
if we run this we'll get X maximum value
2.9798 this really gives us the maximum
value of the Y function
the last question they asked us was how
to find the Y value of Any Given X
this is not something we can do by just
generating all these different points
right that'd be exhaustive I could give
you any x value right
9.99999957892 right and I there's no way
that I was going to calculate that in my
Lin space so at this point we need a
different approach
what we're going to do
is Define something called a custom
function more specifically Matlab calls
these Anonymous functions but they're
just what we're used to when we plug in
a simple value into an equation and we
get one output
and we're going to say at X
Y at x equals this
if we run this we get an error guys I
can honestly never remember how to
define Anonymous functions you know why
because I can open up a new browser
and type Anonymous functions in Matlab
heck I've even made a YouTube video on
this but I don't remember these things
because they're very quick and easy to
look up here we are
we do at uh okay I just forgot to add
parentheses around X not a big deal I
come here parentheses around X
and we're good I run this no more error
but why is defined differently if I
output y right here it's no longer just
this entire thing put through our
function
it's actually a function handle what the
heck is this don't worry so much know
that you can now use Y and plug in any x
value that you want
run that script and there's your answer
it's a massive number also note that
Matlab uses scientific notation here
this is times 10 to the sixth power
but now I think we were asked the Y
value of
20.2 something like that we can run this
and there we go
if we input this value of x we get this
value of y out
these are called Anonymous functions and
they're very quick and easy methods to
get outputs
the problem actually called for us to do
y of 20.7 so I'll go ahead and do that
for you we run that note can be a little
bit confusing because previously we've
done
something like this where X of 2 is
actually the second value in x
note that these are very different X
here is a matrix it's a 1 by 100 array
of values
y isn't a matrix or array there is no
index to y y is defined as a function
handle
these function handles they don't have
multiple components like X does X has
all these values we can choose from y
does not
when we give a value to Y and it's a
function handle
it simply inputs that value and then
runs it through the equation
and that's why these look similar but
act very different
here is another question to consider
plot the equation from x equals negative
10 to 10 of it's that same formula we
saw previously
Part B is going to be we have to change
the curve to add 15 instead of 10 and
then part C is change that curve again
but we're going to do x minus 5 quantity
squared in the parentheses
this is prompting us to think more about
plotting we're going to cover that for
the next few minutes
let's start fresh in Matlab here we've
got X and I've changed this to negative
10 to 10. we aren't going to be using
this Anonymous function form anymore I'm
just going to clean this up to what we
need is the bare minimum
and let's run this to make sure things
are working I've called our y y1 because
for Part B and C we can create a Y2 and
a Y3
I'm just gonna copy this for now it's
gonna be the easiest way to make this
work there's our Y2 and our Y3 will be
like such very good
and our Y2 we add 15 and our Y3 we do
this as a minus five excellent this will
get us our three curves and if we run
this good we've got
100 values for each of these y's and
then we can plot all those values
because it's against the same X right
we're using the same x value negative 10
to 10 for all these different y's and
these will give us our three curves
essentially right now we have three
different pairs of data
but before we get into plotting these
and I want to plot them all side by side
around the same graph potentially let's
just start talking about plots and
figures in Matlab Matlab calls these
things a figure in our Command window
let's just do figure one and hit enter
it's going to open up this window and it
contains a blank figure not very
eventful but as we begin to plot things
on it for example let me do a split
screen here it'll be easier to see
here we go here's our figure that's just
all blank let's do plot X and y1 right
we do this and there we go the plot is
starting to be populated now if I did
plot X and then Y2
we'll see there's a slight very slight
change there actually not substantial
but let me plot the third one now Y3 and
there's a that was a much bigger change
the curved shape is staying the same but
if you look at our axes those are
shifting
what matlab's doing it's rewriting this
graph on the same figure see we still
have figure one right here
the proper way to do this to add
multiple curves of the same plot is
going to be using the hold on command
okay so here I've got Y3 plotted this is
the most recent one that I ran if I did
hold on and then plotted X versus y1 aha
there's our other line let's do that
again hold on and plot X and Y2
there's our third line in yellow there
matlabs automatically recognizing that
these are going to be different lines
and hence it changes the colors being
used
but let's make it ahead of ourselves
this graph is actually pretty crappy we
don't have any actions labels there's no
title this is this is kind of garbage
for now let's let's start a new plot
here let's call figure two
and you know what let's do all this
second figure work back in our script
I'm gonna go full screen here again this
close all is going to wipe out all those
figures and we're starting fresh
let's start with our plot so plot of X
versus y1 we run this we get what we
expect let's add an X label
that's gonna be our x-axis this is
simply X great same thing for the Y axes
let's do y label and Y could not be
simpler you can I like to do these with
a comma but you can put them on separate
lines it doesn't matter you run these
and it's created
we can be more specific here and specify
what figure we want because we can
create multiple figures and plot Y2 on
that second figure
now two figures will pop up here's our
first figure
which has the X and Y on it
and the first curve and here's the
second figure which has our second curve
notice that these X label commands when
they follow a plot they go on that plot
here the X label and Y label commands
come after this first figure plot
and then right here
we plot the second figure but we don't
have any X axes Y axis labels once you
command a plot
anything that follows will go on that
plot until you start another plot
let's keep rolling with this one let's
add a title
using the title command
we call this Y versus X
and we kind of had this as like problem
a from our problem sets so be nice to
have that graft on there too so it
specifies there's our problem a I like
having grid lines on here it makes
things a lot clearer you're just going
to call grid on
run this and we're pretty much there
guys this is looking like a very nice
graph the only thing and this is getting
Nitty Gritty at this point
we should be plotting data points
because these are just simply raw data
points right now right this isn't a
curve this isn't one continuous curve y1
and X1 are 100 data points so we really
should be plotting these as
those Stars
as I talked about earlier
and that way it's a bit more clear I'll
go full screen here to see that we're
just calculating y values at different X
values along the way it creates a shape
of a curve but it isn't overly
misleading of what's going on here
if you want to change the color of these
the shapes of these how do you think
you'd do that what have we talked about
so far when you need to get extra help
on a command
throw this in your command window help
plot scroll up a little bit and you'll
see there's a whole plethora ugh Gold
Guys gold right here blue green red
these are all your oh
blue green red these are all your colors
you can do different shapes and things
and then for your lines you can create
different things here
let's go ahead and do that you add all
those things right in here
so if I wanted to do blue stars I'd do
blue and then star what about blue
circles the o
how about magenta squares let's do MS
I'm not going to plot this figure for
now just the one and there we have
magenta squares kind of fun but very
useful to make sure you're separating
out the different things that you're
plotting on the same graph and that's
what we want to do I want to plot all of
these curves on the same graph
to do that we already discussed the hold
on command let's do plot
X versus Y2 and let's make it something
different let's say we want these to be
I don't know blue triangles I think
that's going to be triangles we can do
that
and then those will be added on note
that we didn't have to add any more X
label and Y label and title stuff
because we already added that to the
figure and now we're just adding another
line here another data set onto the
figure
very cool how this works but you can see
every every Diamond here is simply a
little bit higher than every Square
you can click these points to get the
actual values that you're calculating by
the way and you'll see that we're just
slightly above as you go along the curve
here
last thing we have to plot is going to
be that
final curve let's do Y3 and let's plot
that as I don't know Green
let's do plus signs for now
we'll go ahead and do that and now we
have our green plus signs on there too
but if you just showed someone this
graph they have no idea what equations
you're using they don't know what these
belong to or how they relate what you
need to do is add a legend
go ahead and do the legend command see
this is so straightforward I love
plotting a Matlab I hope you're seeing
how easy this is and straightforward you
just keep adding the things that you
want and Matlab will keep adding those
to your figure we'll do Legend and then
we need to name the legend entries I'll
do y1 Y2 and Y3 note these have to be
given as characters or strings
and then Matlab will add these to our
graph and it goes in order okay so the
first thing you plot will correlate to
the first thing that you name
we do this and Matlab will add an
automatic legend in the top right you
can click and drag this by the way and
move it around so you can make it easier
for your viewers you've also got a lot
of tools built into this chart look on
the right here you click this hand
that's your panning hand
and then if you go and click on the
graph click and hold I can scooch this
and now change the viewing area let's
see how my axes are changing right now
pretty cool after that I can click the
home button to go back
to the actual View
you can zoom in
click the plus magnifier and I want to
zoom in to where all these Peaks are
happening click and drag and now we've
zoomed into all these Peaks pretty cool
I can also zoom out by just clicking the
zoom out and clicking around the screen
here
and you can always go back to the home
at the end
if you want to copy this figure and put
it in another document you'll click the
copy figure button right here and
that'll enable you to open up a
PowerPoint presentation a Word document
or something like that you'll copy the
figure you can also save this figure and
do a couple other things here
but mainly edit copy figure and paste it
into something else
if you want to change the axes ranges
for example yeah we did X from negative
10 to 10 but maybe I just want to hone
in on a specific part you're going to do
x-lim and then pass
a matrix here okay this Matrix is going
to be what you want for your lower limit
I'll say 0 to 2.
so this Matrix is your actual limits
okay
you run this and then you'll see our
x-axis is now just from zero to two
if I wanted to change the y-axis you
guessed it y Lim and I can do this from
zero to a hundred
run this and now you'll see that the y
axis has changed only looking from zero
to a hundred
remember I can still use my pan tool to
look around here and see the other
curves
I can use my magnifying glass to
zoom out a little bit more
see some more of that curve look around
these tools are here for your disposal
last thing if you want these to be
filled in you have a couple attributes
that you can change
so these symbols let's say I want to
fill this in you're going to do an
attribute name and then the value of
that attribute
so here we want to do Marker
face color
and then I want that to be Magento
and let's say I also want to change the
marker size
and I want that to be size 10.
you're probably thinking where is he
getting these things where are these
attributes stored where can I learn more
about these attributes
use matlab's help
scroll around read these things Google
them you can always find more
information on the stuff online and
using the stuff that I've shown you in
the command window
I think it's got them here somewhere
it's going to look for marker size and
see if they use this at all on the page
here we go we've got marker size 10
we've got marker Edge color oh okay so
here they change the edges to kind of a
blue
and I did a marker face color change the
face values you can change the lined
width so those lines that I was plotting
earlier you can change those
let's go back down here
let's plot what we have
here you can now see how our axes are
still kind of off here but there we've
got those squares that are now filled in
a little bit easier to see these green
things are kind of difficult right now
but you get the notion you can play
around with these things you call an
attribute
and then you call
the value you want that attribute to be
and then with your lines if you want to
plot this as a line you can add a dash
dash in front
we do this and you'll see we get a
dashed line with the squares on it if
you want to get rid of the squares well
then you don't specify the shape that
you want to plot
I'm going to get rid of our our limits
here because these are kind of annoying
if you don't specify the shape then
you'll see we just have a dash dash line
that's magenta representing our y1 curve
you'll notice that we've put all of
these three curves on one single plot
and we did that with the hold on command
Matlab also offers us the option to
split these into three different plots
or put them on side by side plots I'll
show you what I mean we can create those
different figures
remember when we did the figure one the
figure two
let's put these all on separate figures
so instead of hold on let's just do a
new figure and a new figure and we don't
need a legend anymore because we're
putting these all on different figures
in fact three figures
let's run this and you'll see that we
now have three figures each for a curve
that's one way to split things up
and then you'd have to add for every
figure
these
you have to do the X label you have to
do the Y label you have to do the title
you need to add all that stuff to
populate these graphs as well
another option you can do and depending
on your application this could be very
useful is using something called
subplots
can do help subplot
and you can learn more about the subplot
approach but what subplots do is
basically you're creating this like a
matrix of graphs you know how we have a
two by two Matrix and we have values in
all those two by two spots we can do
that with plots we can call subplot
I can call two by two here and then
specify the place I want my first plot
let's just call it one for now but this
will create two rows by two columns of
plots get rid of my other figure
commands for now let's just comment
these out so we don't get confused
and I'll show you what this looks like
there okay see how this plot is in the
top left of a two by two
looks like a matrix of graphs almost
right if this is the layout so you can
put these plots it's in the same figure
but it's in a different area of the
actual plotting area
it's kind of hard to describe this with
words but I think you guys are seeing it
from the visual let's say I want to add
all the other curves then in these other
spots
I would do subplot same same subplot
here so you keep the same dimensions
then I'm going to add two because I want
this one in the second position
let's go plot and do this one we'll see
this one come up now in the second
position and it goes top left is one and
then two then three then four
let's get this third plot on there as
well two two let's put this sorry this
one should be in the second spot this
one should be in the third spot
uncomment it and we'll end up with this
beautiful graph again we need to add all
the the labels and the titles for every
one of them if we want that let's go
ahead and just copy those in right below
those plotting commands
those all be populated
but this a two by two isn't the
appropriate approach for these graphs
right what would be better what would be
a more visually appealing method for
this what type of Matrix a 1x5 a 10 by
10
hopefully you're thinking maybe a 1 by 3
or a three by one we've got three graphs
here
let's go ahead and do that let's do one
by three
for all of these
and this will give us one row of three
charts then as we expand this out we get
a nice side by side visualization of
these three plots and that'll be a
sufficient answer to that problem we
started with about how these curves
change with different parameters
let's take a stab at another question
here we see based upon the following
equation what percent of Y values are
greater than 0.8 for x equals 0 to 10 we
have y is the sine of x
this is one that if I'm being honest I
don't even know how I'd solve this
analytically you know with what we said
our equation would be solve for values
at x equals zero and x equals 10 and try
to plug these in and then
look at the the period of the sine wave
so this would be a tough one to do
with paper I honestly don't know how to
do it I'm sure there's proofs and things
like that but if we break this down we
know that the sign of any any input
there will be from negative one to one
so we know that some values should be
greater than 0.8 right we'll have
something between 0.8 and 1 for I don't
know how many X values but that'll
happen so that's at least good so it's
not zero
but we'll need to essentially check
some data points similar to when we
plotted we developed x from 0 to 10 we
calculated some y values and then we had
those individual points that we plotted
remember that we're essentially going to
do that but now we need to check if
those values are greater than 0.8
and then we'll have to sum those up and
see how many we have and divide that by
the total amount that's going to be the
approach for this problem
we have a clean slate and Matlab and
I've got our X going from 0 to 10 and
our Y is just the sine of x nothing too
eventful here I like to plot things
again I'm very visual
I'm going to go ahead and make a plot of
this just so we see we've got an idea
okay let's pop this as as points again
we don't want to confuse ourselves
what's going on just do dot that'll give
us just points
now if we look closely here's 0.8
and it looks like it's going to be some
portion I guess this is around 15 you
can hold me to it we'll see how this
problem goes I have not solved it yet
but we can mean if we were really
desperate we could just count these
points and divide by the total number of
points but I'm trying to teach you guys
basics of logic in this problem
we have our points and we're getting
real fancy what we can do let's do hold
on plot another thing let's plot just
the X values let's do one at zero and
ten
and then let's do Y at 0.8 and 0.8 see
what I'm doing here I'm not creating
actual X and Y things to plug in here
I'm just giving them the direct arrays
so that'll plot point zero zero point
eight and then 10 0.8 that'll give us a
line let's make that a red line
that's dashed
all right let's do that really quick and
now we can get a better visual for we're
looking for all these dots above this
red line kind of cool and we're going to
add some more line I'm sorry we're going
to add some more points here let's make
this
geez hundred thousand points mat level
have no problem for this by the way it
still takes like no time to run but we
have a lot more points now you can't
even see that it's not a line these are
individual points that'll give us a more
accurate answer than if we did I don't
know just 10 points
right this is a very inaccurate approach
you can hardly even tell this is a sine
wave so it's always better to run more
points especially when we have the
computation ability with modern
computers
sounds good we need to check if these
values are greater than 0.8 this is the
bases of logic logic gives true and
false values out after you present a
logic statement
let's start by just saying x equals five
no problem there we're just back to our
Command window
and let's do X is greater than two run
this and we get the logical of one this
is telling us yes your statement here
was true remember cute computers started
with zeros and ones and they still are
zeros and ones by the way we've just
progressed to languages like Matlab we
don't have to type zero zero one zero
one one zero zero but the bases of these
things are still zeros and ones let's do
X is less than two which would be the
answer here if one is true
zero will be false and you can I can
even type true here and get the logical
out of one and I can type false and get
the logical out of 0.
thus if we want to check multiple values
let's define a as just a matrix of ones
let's do a 1 by 10 matrix of one so a
will just be a bunch of ones here
what if we did a is greater than zero
what will come out
mat level performed this logic
assessment on every element of a
one is greater than zero one is greater
than zero one is greater than zero and
thus we're just going to get the Matrix
out of all trues
maybe not the best example let me do a
is ones and then multiply this by five
so we'll have a bunch of fives and now
we can do our logical test a greater
than zero and we get a logical array of
ones out which is telling us true true
true true true true true true right this
is exactly how we get this information
in zeros and ones and now we can use
zeros and ones to easily count I can use
the sum function having been discussed
you probably know it existed sum of a
will give us 50. this is just summing up
these 10 values but if I save result to
the logic statement a greater than zero
my result is this true true true true
true
array and if I sum result I get 10. this
confirms that 10 of the values in a are
greater than zero
there's tons more logic to do guys I'm
going to run through really quick some
of these other logical operators you
could do eight greater than or equal to
eight true
you can do 19 plus 5 is less than
a hundred
true
you can do 55
does not equal to this is a fancy one
here a tilde
20. and that gives you logical of one
because 55 does not equal 20. by the way
on your keyboard this should be like the
very top left shift and hit that one the
dash is what's next to it this little
thing jig
I call it a tilde maybe it's an e tilde
I don't know
other stuff you can do compound checks
so maybe
10 is greater than 5.
and
11 is greater than negative 100.
so this will check is 10 greater than 5
that's true
this will check is 11 greater than
negative 100 that's true and if both of
these are true
then it'll output true
okay this is kind of getting to the
whole field of logic you may or may not
be familiar but these ands require both
of these correct if I did an or
actually let me make one of these false
this is false right 11 is not less than
100 so we get false because both of
these are not true we get false that's
the power of the and
if we look at or when we take this and
do or which is just a vertical bar or
10 is greater than 5 that's true 11 less
than negative 100 that's false but only
one of these has to be true only 10
greater than 5 or 11 less than negative
100. if I run that I'll get true
okay that's all I want to cover on the
logicals but let's go back to our
problem
we have to figure out what percentage of
our values and Y are greater than 1.8
how do we do that
well if a value of 1 is greater than 0.8
that'll give us a one out so maybe we
can compare this entire Matrix of y's
y greater than
0.8 let's see what our output is oh my
goodness yeah we have a lot of values
here we're going to get a ton of stuff a
bunch of zeros here
let's keep scrolling through and see if
we find any ones there's so many values
ah here we are
found a bunch of ones that's good that
means our test worked to some degree
let's sum up those values let's save
this as y I'm going to do y underscore
greater
that's going to hold the array output of
this
so now this will be saved to y greater
I'm going to stop plotting this for now
and y greater is the same size as our y
value but you can see in our workspace
it's got a check next to it because if
we do whose
take a look our y grader is a logical
array
it's not the typical double that we see
before but we can treat this as
something that we can sum up let's do
the sum of y greater
and that'll give us the total number of
values that are greater than 0.8
then we can divide this
by the total number of values that we
generated
and that'll give us the percent of
values that are greater than 0.8 so let
me do
final percent as a variable here
some y we have those values and I'm just
going to divide that by yeah if we could
cheat here we could change this to be
you know we could just copy and paste it
there that's bad form because what if we
change this to 100 values now we have to
change this to 100 values instead let's
do the length of Y
new function Here length of Y will give
us the length of Y how many elements are
in y you can also call height of Y which
would give us the number of rows and you
can call width of Y
and that'll give us
the number
of columns length will always give you
the larger of height and width
great we call length of Y we run this
and we get final percent is 0.25 kind of
cool and now
let's actually ramp this back up make
sure we have more and you can see that
our number changes just slightly here it
increases to be more accurate
if we just do one value yeah we're gonna
get to zero because the one value we
sample didn't actually do anything if we
do 10 samples we say it's about you know
20 of the values and if we increase this
to a thousand we start honing in and the
value doesn't get any any more accurate
so we're just dealing with 0.2574 as the
answer to our question
if you want to technically make this a
percent you can multiply this by 100 and
then change this to be 25.74 percent
this was a super quick intro to logic
statements but very often these things
are super useful for quick checks of
things like we did in this problem
one cool thing we can do is change this
0.8 value and we can now check if things
are greater than 0.5 let's say
but we're also going to want our plot to
update let's create a new variable and
call it
y check that's the value we're checking
against and I'll call it 0.5 for now
and we can replace this
with Y check and Y check
and then this with Y check this is good
programmer form
you want all your parameters to start at
the top
then come in and do your actual actions
and then have your final output
I'm being sloppy here but work with me
you get the idea we start out and we
Define parameters these are the things
that we change very easily and quickly
and it commands the rest of the code
imagine you've got hundreds of lines
here you don't want to go back searching
for wherever this value made sense or
whatever you know you want these things
to be consistent so you can update one
value like why check to zero and then
automatically your code follows suit and
updates in those places
now if we run this code look our line
adjusts to zero and the final percent is
updated as well
if you're wondering why half the values
right if it's a sine curve you should
have should be greater than and then
half should be less than it's because
we're going over like one and a half
periods of a sine curve here if we
adjusted this to be right right here as
where we cut things off
looks like it's about
let's see what is this point here
um
let's actually change this to prove what
I'm saying here looks like it's around I
don't know 6.3 so let's change this to
6.3
what else do we have to change
this value right here to 6.3
so let's now create a variable called
Max X
and do Max X and then this equals 6.3
0 to Max X
we run this
and there we go we have got about it's
about one period then one Crest one
trough and our final percent is just
about fifty percent there I was
eyeballing it but that makes sense it's
a good logic check to know that our code
is running as we expect it to
that's the final lesson to take away
from this as well don't just blindly
send stuff out into the ether and hope
that Matlab is doing it correctly
matlab's doing what you tell it to do
your parents at some point probably told
you that computers are stupid and they
are because they listen to everything
you do and if you're stupid then you're
going to create a stupid output
I'm not calling you stupid but garbage
in is garbage out you can write a crappy
program and it's not going to give you a
good answer
you need to write good programs that you
are confident in and those will give you
confident accurate answers
let's take a stab at this problem
part A is to generate 10 random numbers
from one to five
so randomly generate a three randomly
generated two a four one five this would
be from a uniform discrete distribution
and then we want to count how many
threes there are in Part B we're going
to display the word wow
if there is more than twenty percent of
the numbers being three
in part C we're going to do a and b
again but using a for Loop we'll
introduce the for Loop mentality here
and then we're going to extend this
instead of 10 random numbers to 10
million random numbers and we're going
to compare the speeds and the time it
takes to compute using the two different
methods
we are back to a blank script in Matlab
I'm now using Ubuntu as my operating
system for those using Linux
distributions out there Windows was the
first half of this class nothing changes
by the way it's basically the same exact
approach
the same syntax that Matlab is using
you'll only notice some differences in
the IDE but for learning purposes it's
the exact same just offering potential
Comfort to those of different operating
systems
first thing here as always we're going
to clear everything in the command
window and clear our variables
we need to generate our random numbers
and I'm going to call this Matrix a a
will hold our random numbers
if you want to find some other random
commands feel free to look around the
webs I'm going to use Randy
we can find more about Randy by taping
help Randy
Randy is going to generate integers with
a uniform discrete distribution that's
exactly what we need
let's go ahead and give the arguments
five so if I just run this
a is four if I keep running this script
over and over we're going to see that
that random number changes so this is
generating just one random number from
one to five
I want 10 of them I want a 1 by 10
matrix and here we're getting random
numbers 10 of them from one to five
great
the first thing we need to do was to
count how many threes there were
if you recall we've done some logic
checks
if something's greater than 3 if
something's Less Than 3 if something
does not equal three well let's try just
running something like this the fifth
term equals three so we can check a
single term if it equals three or not
and you'll see in the output there we
just gotta hit logical is one as our
answer and the first second third fourth
the fifth term is three we were
basically just checking this single term
here
remember as we learned we can do this
for whole arrays so we can just check in
general if a is equal to 3 and we'll get
a entire logical array out
in this case we didn't get any threes so
our logic array is just a bunch of zeros
but as we do this in this run we had
looks like four threes
to count this all we do is add a
summation
around our logic statement there which
will sum these up and give us the number
of threes
so here we have two two one two zero two
occasionally we should get three all
right here's three and we wanted to
display wow if this happened
this is where we can introduce the if
statement
the if statement will act if a condition
is true
for example
if
this value here which we discovered was
just outputting three it outputs the
number
of Threes that we have in this a matrix
if that is greater than or equal to
three
then we will output
using the display command wow
and then we have to end at the if
statement
you'll notice that every time we open an
if you have to do an end to the f
this display will simply output to the
command window and we can begin to run
this
there we go there's our first time we
have one two three
four threes in this one and that time we
were able to display wow to the command
window
when this statement right here that I
have highlighted evaluates to true then
we get an output to the command window
because we asked for it right here and
to be thorough for the problem it wants
us to Output the number of threes
so let's go ahead and do this as num
threes equals the sum of a
equals three
and then we can just replace right here
num3
then with our outputs we'll get the
random Matrix a the number of Threes
that we had in The Matrix and when num3
is greater than or equal to three we'll
display wow
run this a few more times so we get one
more hit here
there we are wow we had three sorry we
had five threes in this run and we
displayed wow
that's the basics of the if statement
from here our instructions were to go
ahead and do a for loop with the same
mentality
I'm going to introduce you to a section
notation
to
percent signs side by side introduce a
new section you can see this blue
highlighting here it might be white it
might be black depending on your system
setup we're creating a new section right
now and we can run each of these
sections differently
this will be section one up top
foreign
we can be more specific on what we're
calling them this is the if statement
approach and down below in section two
we have the for Loop approach it's these
double percent signs that Define a new
section the benefit of this is that in
each section we can kind of run them
independently and they act independently
of these other scripts that it's
involved with in the same dot m file
so if I run this script down here and
just say x equals 10 and run this
everything up here is still the same
nothing changed I only ran this section
got my output of x equals 10 and a new
variable was created
if I do CLC and clear vars down here and
run this
it's as if I'm just running this own
section here which is what I'm doing
Matlab only runs each section
independently
control enter is the best way to run
your independent sections you can also
come up here to your run button you've
also got run section on the left
and that'll be your section depending on
where you're running if you use the Run
button in general it'll go through and
it will run the entire script
as you can see we end up with just x
equals 10 at the end because of this CLC
and clearvar statement
run will always run the entire script
run section just runs the individual
section that your cursor was in
that's because that's the active section
and Matlab assumes you want to run that
individual section
let's start with a clean slate to
discuss for loops
for Loops are more advanced programming
techniques and can be very challenging
for beginners so please don't be put off
I promise you you'll get it
they're useful when you need to do the
same thing over and over again
you do a for Loop for a specified number
of iterations and then it stops and the
rest of the code will continue to run
of course it's best demonstrated with an
example
let me go ahead and write a for Loop for
I equals 1 through 10. let's just output
I and then end the loop
I'm going to run this
and we're going to see in our output
that I is just being outputted
1 to 10.
so what's going on here
well you know one to ten right you've
seen this before if we just do that in
our Command window
it's going to do what just give us 10
values one to ten no surprise here
but we're using this variable I
and this could be any variable it
doesn't have to be I I is just what's
typically used you could call it a
counter if you want to and then change
this to counter and counter is going to
go from 1 to 10 you could call it
your friend
in case you don't have any friends
now you're oh look at the end you have
friends that are you have 10 friends see
look at that programming's beautiful
the fact is we're going to call this I
and it's a placeholder value that you're
using in each of your Loops but what's
actually looping what's what is this
Loop iteration that we talk about
every time this runs
the value of I will change
I starts at 1
I equal to one
and then this code is executed if I have
multiple lines like I plus 1 and display
I and all these things in here all this
stuff between the four and the end
is run with I equal to 1.
so if I run this
and scroll up
during that first iteration oh
let me just clear some stuff here
sorry about that so you'll see
and clear vars
so we just have a clean output
here we get I equals one and then I
added I plus 1
and then I just simply displayed the
letter i which happened right there
see how I displayed the letter I and not
the actual value which would be
I like that
just the letter i
so every Loop
every time we run this code the value of
I will change it starts out as I equals
one because we asked it to right here in
the next Loop
once it hits end it goes back up
it goes back up and I becomes 2.
right here I equals 2 because of this
statement here
then we add I plus 1 and we get the
answer out to be three and then we
display the letter I right here I
that's all the commands so we go back up
I now becomes three
I equals three three plus one is four
display the letter I and we do this over
and over and over
until we get to 10 which is why the last
Loop is I equals 10 I plus 1 is 11 and
display the letter i
we get to set the number of Loops right
we're telling Matlab we only want I to
go from 1 to 10.
if I want I to go from 1 to 10 skipping
every other number there remember just
like we did
earlier this will go one three five
seven nine if I run the code
I is 1 then I is 3 I is 5.
i7 I is 9 and we have all the other
outputs that we asked for as well
this is for Loops while Loops are
different and we'll cover them later
how does this relate to what we're
trying to do though in our problem we're
trying to count the number of Threes how
is this even useful
for Loops are very useful for going
through numbers and a matrix
we can use this I
as an index
so we could go through and if we called
I or sorry a like we had up here
we could call a of one
we could call af5 and we can go through
and then do checks on each of the
individual components
let's generate this random a matrix down
here now
and instead of going from one by you
know 1 to 10 here let's just go from one
to the length of a
and the length of a will be what
it will just be 10 because it's a 1 by
10 matrix and 10 is the longest
dimension
we'll go through from 1 to 10 and I'm
going to check all these values inside
a
I
will start with this let's run this what
will happen
I is 1 to start we run this and this is
equivalent to running a parentheses 1
which gives us the first term of a
on the next loop I becomes 2
this becomes a 2. which gives us the
second term of a
so it'll end up printing out
line by line here what a is here a two
one four four two one four four it's
just going through each of those indices
we want to do a logic check right we
want to see if that value is going to be
greater than or equal to 3.
count the number of threes
so we can do a
is equal to 3 here
and we'll get logicals out right we're
getting all these logicals now zero zero
zero zeros all the way down we get oh
geez three threes in a row at the end
there they are
now we need to count these
ideally we'd establish some sort of
num3 variable again
that will equal the previous value and
we'll just add one to it so every every
Loop that we get this to be true ah we
should make this an if statement so we
should do if
AI is equal to 3. then we run this
and we'll end that if statement
this is called a nested if statement
because it's inside of another loop
nested if
so if
this term of a is equal to 3
if that evaluates to true then we do
this
we say num3 is equal to the previous
value of num3 and we add 1 to it we're
counting these values of three as we go
through the Matrix
if we try to run this
we have no threes in that one but here
we have a three and we're going to get
an error and that's because we didn't
Define num3 before this Loop started so
Matlab tried to grab num3 it doesn't
exist
we need to add num3 equals zero to start
because our count of numbers of Threes
is zero we have no no threes yet until
we start going through the loop and we
count every time that this is added
let's run it
there we are num3 equals one
run it again we get two outputs here
right because the first time we had a
hit we outputted and the second time we
had a hit we outputted and it added one
great and then at the end we can add
just the same logic statements
right here we can display wow if num3 is
greater than or equal to three
run this a few times let's see if we get
there we are with our wow if you don't
want to have that output every time you
can just simply add a semicolon there
and we'll just get wow
a bit more complicated and it is for
this simple example
but it's often good to learn on examples
where you know the answers are true so
that you can check your for loops with
it
the final part of this problem was to
calculate it with 1 million variables
as in we're going to generate one
million random numbers and let's run
these side by side now
I like to make my sections when I'm
initially learning how to do these
things so it keeps it separate now that
they're both running let's go ahead and
bring this together
going to get rid of the section notation
I'm going to add a comment down here
still so we know this is the for Loop
area and just for Loop
we only need to generate one
Matrix of random values
and then let's see what else we need to
do num3 here we don't want to have the
same variable that we're using for these
different areas so let's go ahead and
name this one num3 underscore
if because it relates to the if
statement stuff we're doing
and then we can just leave these as
number three down here
and actually we should be good
programmers and name it
num34 right and you can see too Matlab
offers depressed shift and enter to
rename the other two instances I like
that and now we have num34 and we have
num3f in the other section
we can run this all together and we
should get outputs only when we have the
Wows you'll see we get two Wows because
both sections are displaying them here
we can suppress this output as well if
we want and we'll just get the random
Matrix and our Wows out
the last thing was to compare the times
with a million I got distracted there so
we want to make this a million so here's
a hundred
thousand million 10 million I believe is
what it asked for 10 million points
let's run this oh dear make sure that
you no longer output a as you can see
your computer is going to try to
output a million values now in your
uh command window make sure you suppress
that
and notice how greater than or equal to
3 no longer is applicable right we're
always going to get that with a million
10 million values
we want to make this 20 percent so 0.2
times the number of values generated so
times the length of a
same down here greater than or equal to
0.2
times the length of a
good so that way this comparison
statement here
will change as we change our a value
sorry change the length of a
now if we run this oh I have an error
this should be length fully spelled out
and good we're able to run this now
sometimes we output wow sometimes we
don't makes absolute sense
to time it to get the duration of time
it takes to run a specific section of
code what you need to do is use matlab's
built-in function tick and talk
tick is where you want to start timing
something
and talk is where you want to end it
if we run this Matlab will automatically
give us an output about the elapsed time
between tick and talk
to save these as variables let's call
time if which is the time it took to run
the if section
you do that equal the talk we run that
and you'll see we get time F here
0.0040 so these are in seconds by the
way seconds
let's do the same thing for the four
section add tick and at the end add tuck
we want to save that as time underscore
4 equals talk
run this and we have two different times
here
the time to run the if statement
what is this four thousandths yeah tens
hundreds thousands point zero zero four
seconds here a time to run the four
statement section
is .0450
it seems pretty insignificant right
that's both less than a second we have
all the time in the world right now
we're in no rush but this is actually a
huge huge insight into some of the
challenges that we see in Computing for
Loops in general are going to be slower
and right now does it matter in our
script no we're not even waiting a
second to run this it's hardly
significant
but imagine if you had a script that
took four days to run
write your if statement version of it
took four days and you're for your for
Loop statement version of it took 45
days
right that's that's a pretty big deal
and even if it's the difference between
four minutes and 40 minutes is a big
difference right so when you're making
your code and your scripts you want to
consider the most optimized method and
this is something that takes years of
practice I just want to introduce you to
it now so you're aware tick and talk are
great ways to know what's fast and
what's not
the if statement method this is
typically called vectorization because
you're just dealing with vectors here
I'm not going through each individual
term I'm doing whole checks on entire
vectors right these logic checks I'm
performing rather than going through and
looking at each individual term of that
random Matrix
so try to vectorize as much as you can
but again
write stuff that's simple and
understandable when you start and then
you can look towards this optimization
later on
we ran to a couple things here that I
want to point out the first are going to
be naming conventions you'll see I'm
using some underscores I'm using some
you know capital letters
there's a couple good ways you want to
create variables
there's two main methods
the first
is going to be called a camel case and
that's where you do this camel case
under under what is this lowercase first
letter and then when you have a compound
word you capitalize the second part of
it
this could be then let's just total
revenue
equals seven
you can also do total underscore Revenue
equals eight
or whatever
these are the two main methods
underscoring you just keep everything
lowercase and that underscores between
compound things and then total revenue
is an example of camel case where you
uppercase those other letters for the
compound words
you want your variable names to be as
descriptive as possible a bad variable
name for example would be four right
four is a word that Matlab already
assigns for doing for Loops so you can't
say four equals nine
it's going to be thrown off what you're
trying to do here similarly you
shouldn't name your variables after any
functions like the sum
should not equal
10 that's bad because what if you're
trying to use the sum function you know
the things that you want to keep clear
so don't use variable names that are the
same as function names you also can't
use numbers to start your variable name
so I can't do
2016 total revenue if I run that well I
could try doing yeah see okay matlab's
already telling me look you're missing
multiplication it thinks I'm doing this
multiplication here multiplying between
something else if I still insisted no I
want to save this as a variable
2016 whatever whatever year that might
be right it's going to give me that
error because it thinks I'm trying to do
math so you can't start with
numbers you have to start with letters
here
foreign
the other thing I want to show you is
how to do your file names we can create
new files using the new script here
you can also use the plus sign right
next to your current and go between and
you can have multiple scripts open here
this is very useful when you're working
on things
at the same time you can use Ctrl s to
save these really quickly and make sure
you have the dot m file extension the
dot m extension is needed to save Matlab
files
let's say I want to name this file 2016
Revenue like before dot m if I click
save matlab's going to yell at me I
cannot start with a number
Matlab file names must start with a
letter and contain only letters numbers
and underscores
home stretch guys the last topic we're
going to cover are while loops and
custom functions while Loops are in the
same family as for Loops they look
similar the way we construct them but
they have one key difference
in a for Loop you decide how many times
you want to run right for I equals 1 to
20 for I equals 5 to 50. you're going to
display
the variable I and then end you know how
many times this is going to run right
it's predictable you're telling it how
many Loops to run here
output is as expected just explain the I
as we go through this case I'm
displaying the variable I not just the
letter I like we did previously
here we just see a bunch of eyes
in a while loop
while
we have to give it some condition here
and then we do actions and then we end
let's do well the condition and the
condition will be something like Z is
greater than five or the sum of values
is greater than nine it'll be one of
those conditional statements we've been
doing
such as
10 greater than
five and whenever that condition is true
the while loop will run
once that condition is false the while
loop stops
so you can see that we no longer have
direct control over how many Loops are
run but instead we have control over the
conditional statement
Let's do an example Z equals 100
while Z is greater than 75 we do stuff
we display let's just say the square
root of Z I don't know up to you
and then
we have to add a key statement which I
think of as the reduction statement
you have to force eventually this
statement to become false
otherwise you get in an infinite Loop
scenario okay if I were to run this
right now and I'll do it for you I may
crash the computer but let's go ahead
and run this it's just outputting tens
you can't tell right now this thing is
just going going going going I have to
force quit with Ctrl C okay you might
even hear my laptop it's revving up
right now it was just infinitely
outputting tens I can show you my like
I'm scrolling right now look at it's
just 10 10 I mean infinitely this would
have gone on forever
force quit with Ctrl C if you ever hit
this issue
why did that happen well Z was a hundred
right so the square root of 100 was 10
which just kept outputting and then it
went back up to the top evaluated as Z
greater than 75 well yeah it absolutely
is oh you don't need that semicolon by
the way every time is z greater than 75
sure Z is still a hundred is 100 greater
than 75 yes do this yes do this yes do
this over and over and over until you've
got a ton of outputs that you just have
to control C to stop this
so
we need a statement in here that's going
to reduce the value of Z
to make this statement false
simple one
Z equals z minus 1.
we run this
it stops we have a set number of values
and we're just giving the square root of
Z
and this we decrease the value so now Z
becomes 99 99 is greater than 75.
98 is greater than 75 all the way you
can see we get to 81 at some point here
because the square root of 81 is 9 and
then eventually we hit a stopping point
when Z is equal to
76 this will be true one last time we'll
decrease
76 to 75 and then 75 is not greater than
75 that will be false and it ends
and then anything you want here
I'm gonna add Loop ended it's a little
reminder for us we run this and we get
our little display afterwards because
the script keeps on running afterwards
the last thing I wanted to show you guys
was how to make this into a separate
function
you're going to end up with a very
complicated things very complicated
Expressions very complicated
mathematical formulas you know even all
these the nested Loops the nested if
statements it becomes easier at a
certain point to create a separate.m
file to handle all those things and then
you can just run those that m-files from
your main dot m file
let's create a new script and we're
going to use it as a function
Matlab has a great built-in feature for
this click the drop down by new and
select function
it gives you all the basic structure
that you need
to create a function you're going to
start with function and then Define what
output arguments you want
this should be the name of the function
here
and then you're going to add input
arguments
all this inside will be using your input
arguments to create your output
arguments
in our case we're just going to be
running our while loop
let's take this stuff right here
and let's replace it in here
while Z is greater than 75 display
square root of Z yes we're going to get
rid of this line we don't need to
display these things
but we just want to reduce it down
so let's let's plan for this to be more
General case so let's have our output be
the final Z value Z final
and we'll have our input just be Z
let's call this function
reduce Z with an underscore in there and
we need to save it as that same name
reduce underscore Z dot m
this is where the current folder matters
we need this file this dot m file to be
in the same folder as our main script
which I have Basics here
that way these two files can interact
with each other because they're in the
same current folder
now for reduce Z what we'll do is we
receive a z value
and let's say that's Z initial
let's set Z equal to Z initial
no output needed and then while Z is
greater than
Z
initial
we're going to reduce the value of Z
and this will become
Z final
so actually
no let's keep this as Z for now
and then at the end of everything
we'll save Z
to Z final
equals z
okay so we bring in z
let's think how this is going to go
through so if we give an input of 75
like we did before
as our argument to this function reduce
Z
75
is saved to Z
while 75 is greater than Z initial this
doesn't work let's do this divided by 2.
so while 75 is greater than 75 over 2
then we reduce Z every Loop
until it gets to this point which will
happen because we're reducing it
eventually we'll get down to you know Z
over 2 and then we'll be final this is a
little bit complicated guys I know I'm
just trying to show you this function
notation and we'll output Z here and
this is the final is what we have is our
output to our function
let's save this we'll go back to basics
don't need this anymore all we need to
do is run our function
which we called reduce Z
let's give it the argument of Z and
we'll see what happens here
we run this and we get our answer out to
be 50.
don't need this anymore either
does that make sense to us we're giving
a value of a hundred this is the one
argument that we're giving to our
function so the value of 100 is passed
to the function reduce Z
we go into reduce Z
here Z initial is set to 100.
100 is saved to Z
is 100 here
while 100 is greater than 100 over 2. so
while Z is greater than 50
we take Z which is 100 to start and we
decrease it by one
so it goes down to 99. now we're 99
greater than 50.
we Joe would go again we reduce so now
it's 98 97 96 95 all the way until
Z is going to be what 51 Z is 51 greater
than this
oh no 51 will be true so 51 greater than
50 yes Z is reduced down to 50.
50 greater than this no
false we end the while loop and then we
save 50 which is z to Z final
Z final is then our final output for the
function
and that gives us this answer of 50.
I know
it's crazy
it is very hard to get your mind around
this if you're struggling do not worry I
have entirely separate YouTube videos on
these topics these last ones these for
Loops while loops and functions they are
challenging
don't back down think of it as a way
that you need to push yourself to
understand these Advanced parts of the
programming language
question for you
what if I put
75 here
what would be the final answer
well think eventually we're going down
to the Z over two that's the initial
over two so it'll be 75 over 2.
which would be 37.5
when Z is 38
this will still be true because 38 is
greater than will reduce down to 37 and
that should be the last Loop so let me
run this and 37 is inevitably our answer
holy cow guys
I think we did it we covered so many
topics in this video I'm amazed if you
stayed to the end kudos to you this is
one of the best beginner crash courses
that I could come up with for you guys
more videos on the channel This was
meant to give you foundations
now from here I encourage you to dive
into specific topics that you need to do
for whatever project or whatever you're
just curious about doing a Matlab
thank you for watching seriously this
channel has been growing because of
people like you who are committed to
learning programming and I'm committed
to helping you learn the program
thank you so much for watching please
like this video please subscribe engage
on the channel I answer any single
question that you guys want to ask I'm
happy to clarify I'm happy to make more
videos just let me know I am here to
help you excel in your programming
experience
cheers and have a great day